bonsoir maurice lemoine et le premier
réaction à cette décision de
l'administration en trump à quoi joue
donald trump selon vous à une semaine de
la fin de son mandat politique de la
terre brûlée
écoutez ma première réaction d'un joueur
c'est de me dire que si actuellement
washington est quasiment l'état de siège
avec 10000 ou quinze mille cartes
nationaux qui sont arrivés pour le
disent pas c'est pas du et c'est pas à
cause du terrorisme organisé par par
cuba mais du fait de l'ineptie le sort
de son président que et on est dans la
même idée ti en fait en quand il s'agit
de remettre cubain sur la la liste des
organisations qui parrainent le
terrorisme ghana n'a pas beaucoup il ya
la corée du nord à l'iran et à la syrie
jusqu'à peu il ya belle soudan mais le
soudan a reconnu l'état d'israël donc il
n'est plus sur la liste des états
terroristes voyez ça tient pas à grand
chose et en réalité le jeu des matons p
o qui a pris ses distances avec trump
mais qui est toujours dans la même ligne
la belle mine politique c'est en gros
déjà de mettre un les obstacles devant
la politique de bayonne qui sans doute
souhaiterait reprendre celles qui
avaient qu'avait mise en oeuvre barack
obama qui avait retrouvé retrouvé des
des relations correctes et normal avec
avec cuba et puis c'est aussi parce que
même si tron pour sait pas trop ce qui
va devenir mais je veux dire le le
combat politique entre démocrates et
républicains va continuer c'est aussi un
gage aux électeurs de floride vous savez
que la floride a été un des états des
états clés de l'alternateur élections et
30 peut d'abord portée de près tout et
pour les prochaines élections qui auront
lieu dans quatre ans ou dans deux ans ou
dans cinq angles en six ans il faut
garder cet électorat pour les
républicains
que penser de cette accusation états
soutenant le terrorisme sur quoi se
basent tel le roseau base vous allez
voir c'est complètement absurde en
réalité se base sur deux éléments
principalement le premier élément c'est
la présence à cuba de guérilleros
colombiens
alors vous savez il y avait en colombie
de guérilla principal les forces armées
révolutionnaires de colombie qui ont
signé un accord de paix en 2016
et puis il ya une deuxième guérilla qui
s'appelle l'armée de libération
nationale qui elle
et toujours en activité et qui avait
entamé des négociations avec le
gouvernement colombien et il se trouve
que cuba a prêté son territoire pour
qu'ait lieu ces négociations et le
président d'extrême droite ivan bouquet
qui est un grand ami d'ailleurs de dan
30 a rompu les négociations avec cuba il
a demandé à cuba d'extrader les
dirigeants de la guérilla est donné dès
extradé vers la colombie c'est une
absurdité totale on peut pas extrader
les gens qui sont dus pour négocier et
évidemment cuba a refusé
et puis il ya un deuxième élément c'est
que les etats-unis reprochent à cuba son
appui au venezuela du président nicholas
rigolo vous savez la situation qui a
entre le venezuela et les états unis en
prétendant que en aidant le venezuela
cuba favorise la présence de terroristes
sur le territoire vénézuélien ce qui est
évidemment une aberration quelles
conséquences pour areva ce que cela peut
compliquer les futures relations entre
cuba et joe biden bah ça va en imaginant
que byron et l'intention de normaliser
les relations avec cuba ça va lui
compliquer la sauverait du compliquer la
situation parce que il peut pas revenir
d'un trait de crayon sur une décision
comme ça qui était une décision du
département d'état il faudra une
révision formelle de ce placement sur
les listes héroïque par département
d'état ça prendra du temps et évidemment
ça va ça va poser des difficultés
supplémentaires pour cuba c'est la
poursuite d'une guerre d'agression la
même guerre d'agression que si elle
tient lieu contre le venezuela puisqu'un
trump a renforcé le ce qu'on appelle le
blocus à l'embargo qui dure depuis
maintenant 60 ans avec l'objectif très
clair d'asphyxier l'économie de l'île
il a il a interdit les croisières il a
interdit les vols il vient de prendre
des mesures aux récentes et donc dans un
en plus dans une période de pandémie
pour port cuba par exemple qui a des
problèmes pour se faire livrer du
pétrole du fait de ce blocus des états
unis on est un pays de 11 millions
d'habitants sans carburant c'est
quasiment un acte de piraterie est par
ailleurs à cuba la fin ce 1er janvier du
système de double monnaie
cela peut attirer les investisseurs
étrangers les touristes sur l'île et
donc peut-être faire revenir les devises
et donner du baume au coeur à lille
alors si on le sait c'est cette réforme
de la monnaie n'a pour le coup l'avenir
nous dira d'abord quelques quelles
conséquences ça va avoir sur la
population cubaine
en ce qui concerne le retour des
investissements étrangers ben là encore
on est on est quand même dépendant de la
politique des états unis dans la mesure
où un certain nombre d'entreprises
n'osent pas ou ne veulent pas ou ne
peuvent pas travailler avec cuba parce
que il tombe sous le coup des sanctions
des sanctions les états unis où ça vexe
est maintenant une vous l'évoquiez tout
à l'heure avec la faire du vin en france
mais n'y a pas que ça je veux dire il ya
le le gazoduc north stream nov une deux
qui doit approvisionner en gaz russe
l'allemagne qui est l'objet de sanctions
il ya là le venezuela le biais de
sanctions
on est face à une politique de notre
homme qui est extrêmement brutal la
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
bayonne va l'assouplir l'adoucir us
qu'il va reprendre une politique plus
plus humaine et plus consensuelle par
rapport à la communauté internationale
on imagine que c'est une décision tout
tombe évidemment mal dans un contexte
est également difficile à cuba par des
features il part évidemment la crise
sanitaire occupa du temps telle manière
j'irai cuba est habitué à l'hostilité
des etats-unis l'hostilité de trump il
faut aussi rappeler quand même que des
pays comme cuba ne sont pas complètement
isolé puisque ils ont trouvé des alliés
dans leur précisément dans la communauté
internationale avec la russie avec
l'iran avec un certain nombre de pays
mais évidemment ça ne fait qu'ajouter
aux difficultés de de cuba qui a des
difficultés économiques et comme tous
les pays du monde qu'on me confronter à
la pandémie est évidemment ces mesures
sont complètement non seulement stupide
mais
pause à des problèmes y compris il
comprit aabye dont un qui va devoir
gérer cette difficulté supplémentaire
merci beaucoup maurice lemoine
journaliste spécialiste de l'amérique
latine